willkommen meine Lieben MitbürgerInnen
zu dieser ersten
adventsansprache mein Freund ist viel zu
begeistert von Set und Lichtsetzung und
deshalb befinden wir uns hier in dieser
prekären Situation das ist aussieht als
ob ich live aus dem Buckingham Palace
[Musik]
willkommen zu vlogmes Nummer 1 dieses
Jahr möchte ich Block muss ein bisschen
anders gestalten und deshalb versuche
ich jeden Adventssonntag eine neue Folge
rauszubringen vielleicht kommt noch
dazwischen ein anderes Video oder eine
andere Vlog mit Folge aber bis jetzt
steht der Plan und ich versuche es so
und deshalb versuche ich die Woche ein
bisschen durch zu kommentieren damit wir
einen roten Faden haben ich habe nämlich
beim vloggen gemerkt dass es super
schwer ist eine Woche lang zu filmen und
immer auf andere Aufnahmen anzuschließen
dass man wenn man zusammenschneidet
merkt was gerade wann wieso passiert und
wie startet man nun in die perfekte
erste Block Woche natürlich indem man
die Wohnung aufräumt und dekoriert und
dafür sind wir erstmal im Keller
willkommen
Nummer 1 zu vloggen ist Tag
ach nee nicht Tag wir wollen nicht
täglich Block müssen wir mal eins und
jetzt geht's im Keller weil wir wollen
die weihnachtsde
koration
[Musik]
mal geschneit was war gestern für ein
Tag der
oder so ganz trauriger Schneemann
[Musik]
willkommen zu unserem Keller
sind wirklich sehr schwer
oh nein oh jetzt hast du was gebrochen
du gehst zu Obi und holst mir eine neue
wirklich
kannst du nicht sein Timo
[Musik]
doch gar nicht gezeigt dass wir umgebaut
haben
okay seid ihr bereit für die Wohnungstür
2.0 wer sich erinnert weiß das ist
anders aussah aber jetzt sieht es so aus
den Esstisch haben wir hier hingestellt
der stand vorher da hinten in der Ecke
und die Couch stand andersrum an der
Wand und der Fernseher war oben an der
Wand
und jetzt haben wir ein richtiges
Wohnzimmer und gestern 19.11 hat es das
erste Mal in Berlin geschneit und so
richtig doll also ich glaube ein Tag
vorher ist auch schon wieder bisschen
geschneit aber also gestern war so
richtig Schnee ich habe gedacht das ist
einfach ein Zeichen jetzt ist Zeit jetzt
müssen wir dekorieren jetzt geht's los
hast du dich auch über den Schnee
gefreut ja
schön freust du dich jetzt auf locken
ist wie wie gespannt bis auf die
nächsten Wochen
ja jetzt komm jetzt müssen wir aber auch
anfangen erstmal und mit dein Zeug
packen
oh ja was überhaupt drin bleibt okay
werden nie Weihnachtsmusik und plötzlich
hat er hier Weihnachtsdecke
so viele Lichterketten ich hätte dich
niemals einfach irgendwas kaufen lassen
dürfen
Schneeflocken für die fernbedienste
okay du mit deinen drei Kissen ich zeig
mal was ich so habe der Deckel
eigentlich wollte ich noch so Weihnacht
geladen kaufen aber die sind jetzt schon
sehr atypische künstlich aus irgendwie
finde du leitest ein indem du die Kissen
drauf packst 3 2 1 1
so ich habe mich jetzt umgezogen und mir
ein Weihnachtsstimmung zu bringen
[Musik]
und so sieht jetzt das fertige Ergebnis
aus
ach Christmas
[Musik]
am Montag startete meine Woche damit
dass ich den letzten Kalender ausgepackt
habe Halleluja und es ist einfach ein
sehr aufregender Moment für mich gerade
denn das ist der allerletzte
Adventskalender den ich auspacke ich
glaube dieses Jahr habe ich 25
Adventskalender ausgepackt und das ist
wirklich schon in zehn gewesen also
jetzt zum Ende hin habe ich gemerkt die
Luft ist ein bisschen raus am Anfang gar
kein Problem da habe ich drei teilweise
an einem Tag ausgepackt und ähm ja aber
zum Ende hin das ist ja vorher schon
immer so noch ein aber ich hatte mir
auch so viele vorgenommen und so viele
bestellt ich meine das ist das ist nur
die Hälfte an Müll und dann Kalendern
was hier noch so rum liegt der hat mir
schon mal eine Verlosung gemacht ab
morgen beginnt endlich ein neues also ab
jetzt beginnt eigentlich schon das
work-mas Kapitel das geht so ein nahtlos
ineinander rüber und ihr könnt einfach
nicht ahnen wie froh ich darüber bin
dass dieses Zimmer bald wieder betretbar
ist ich habe gestern mir Videos
angeschaut über bessere blockkameras ich
finde diese Kamera schon sehr gut ich
bin schon auf der Suche nach dem Mikro
für diese Kamera weil ich mal so ein
ansteckungsrohr dafür gekauft habe aber
was mir aufgefallen ist und was auch in
diesem Video gesagt wurde die ist halt
überhaupt nicht weit wirklich wenn ich
euch was vom Hintergrund zeigen möchte
muss ich meinen Hand so weit
rausstrecken und wenn ich euch den Raum
zeige habe ich das Gefühl man sieht ja
kaum was also ja ich hätte gerne
mehr Weitwinkel und danach konnte ich
endlich mein Zimmer wieder aufräumen ich
habe die Gardine im Hintergrund
weggemacht ich habe die Pakete umgeräumt
ich habe alles für die Verlosung
vorbereitet ihr seht ihr zum Beispiel
die Kiste das sind zwei Kisten gefüllt
mit Adventskalender Inhalten die ich
auch noch in verlosungs Boxen reinpacken
werde das war so ein gutes Gefühl nach
über 2 Monaten Adventskalender auspacken
ich bin ja so eine verwöhnte
influencerin dass ich immer Pakete
bekomme und dann nicht mehr so werden
jetzt schon wieder geschrieben und ich
habe sogar ein hallo Vanessa dazu
bekommen meint in Bali nutrition ich
habe mir Ingwer Kapseln gekauft
privat ohne irgendwas also privat halt
ich will hier auch gar keine Werbung
dafür machen ich möchte das auch ein
bisschen dokumentieren wie es mir nach
diesen Ingwer Kapseln geht da ist
nämlich Vitamin D3 und K2 drin und das
soll dann halt gut für den Körper sein
und da wir in den Winter reingehen
möchte ich halt gut gestärkt das
Immunsystem haben also gibt's jetzt
immer
einmal am Tag
zwei Ingwer Kapseln ich habe ein
bisschen Angst dass wenn ich die nehme
dass man davon so ein Ingwer Atem kriegt
wenn man gucken probieren es aus
oh mein Gott was passiert hier ich fühle
mich plötzlich so stark wenn halt seit
drei Jahren keine Sonne mehr scheint da
muss man es halt anders regeln ne
am Dienstag ging es dann auch schon nach
Köln ich hatte nämlich einen großen Dreh
vor mir ihr seht gleich auch was wir
gedreht haben einen wunderschönen guten
Tag wir sind im Auto auf dem Weg nach
Kölle
das Auto ist voll geparkt mit Equipment
denn wir werden dort was drin was
richtig cool ist und ja wir fahren jetzt
hier so rum
wir freuen uns wir freuen uns schauen
wir mal was wird was wird wir sind aber
dann zum Glück sehr gut durchgekommen
haben eingecheckt in unser Hotel wir
haben uns für
flanderische für den pflanzlichen Hof
entschieden wir sind wirklich die
Reiseexperten nicht einmal auf Toilette
gewesen absolut durchgefasst
perfekt gut gemacht anni danke haben das
Auto in die Tiefgarage geparkt was ein
kleines Abenteuer war zu den Leuten
schon erzählt dass ich mein anderes Auto
im Parkhaus kaputt gefahren habe und
dann haben wir unseren palastbezogen
unser Hotelzimmer ähm was tun sie in
meinem Hotelzimmer
schneckbox schönen guten Tag aus unserem
tollen Hotelzimmer hier
das ist eigentlich alles aber es hat
alles was es braucht und vor allem liebe
Damen und dann kurz frisch gemacht und
sind dann raus um noch ein paar Stunden
in Köln genießen zu können vielleicht
sind wir auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt
gelandet und vielleicht haben wir einen
Glühwein getrunken und vielleicht sind
wir dann natürlich zum Koreaner essen
gegangen in Köln hat so gute koreanische
Restaurants ganz besonders hunki
Nummer 1
freut sich ready
lecker aus
ja ja hier haben wir einmal
das ist so lecker dieses Wochenende
[Gelächter]
erstmal so langsam essen wow
guten Appetit Kinder wenn ihr irgendwann
mal in Köln seid kommt zur hunki
bestellt euch tobock hier ist es so geil
macht mir nämlich alles ist lecker das
Chicken ist mega geil Hammer mach keine
Werbung dafür dann ist es immer voll
hier und ich konnte wieder meine somax
Skills zeigen ist eine koreanische Bier
und Soju Mischung da schüttet man
einfach so schön ein Glas und dann kommt
hier oben drauf und eigentlich hat man
da noch mit einem Essstäbchen rein das
habt ihr vielleicht in meinem Soul
travel Vlog Video gesehen travel Vlog
video
oder wie sagt man in Soul
Kombi
und da muss anders stellen
sehr schnell wieder zu Ende war weil wir
mussten am nächsten Tag sehr früh
aufstehen
vorbereitung ist alles wir sind jetzt
wieder zurück im Hotel und ich habe
geduscht
und gucke jetzt bitte den Fernsehen das
ist ein ganz tolles Hotel Rieger
Wellness Barbereich
[Musik]
und warum mussten wir früh aufstehen na
weil wir ein drei Cocktails die ballern
gedreht haben ich habe dafür eine Küche
in Köln gemietet good morning in the
morning und willkommen aus unserem
heutigen
Kochstudio aber wir werden nicht kochen
wir machen heute hier
drei Gottes
so geil es ist eine Special Folge warum
verrate ich euch noch aber ja ich finde
die Küche super super schön und super
clean und das habe ich mir gewünscht wir
machen jetzt den Live-Test ob Kelly uns
einen Kaffee bringen würde wenn wir sie
danach fragen hallo Kelly
wir sind jetzt schon dort ja wir sind
gerade angekommen haben die Sachen
hochgebracht und wir wollten dich fragen
ob du wenn du herkommst und vielleicht
einen Kaffee mitbringen kann also
vielleicht ein Star wie wenn es geht
willkommen in unserem Zeitraffer wie wir
jetzt aufbauen
[Musik]
ein bisschen Weihnachten reingebracht ja
aber warum komme ich denn jetzt extra
nach Köln und Miete eine Küche für
Cocktails die ballern das liegt daran
dass wir dieses Mal das erste Mal nach
fünf Jahren sechs Jahren ein Sponsor
haben für dieses Video der macht das
hier möglich und ich freue mich sehr
jetzt müssen eigentlich nur noch die
zwei Chaoten kommen oh wer konnte
für dich Koffein frei
Christmas Edition yes Christmas Kelly
freust du dich auf diesen Dreh ja
es ist 9 Uhr morgens ich freue mich für
Alkohol reinzuschallern ja und dann
haben wir es gedreht und natürlich habe
ich keine einzige Aufnahme davon ne ich
war so in meinem Film wir hatten aber
trotzdem auch wenn es so kurz war eine
echt schöne Zeit miteinander ich merke
immer dass wir irgendwie viel zu wenig
Zeit verbringen aber Köln Berlin ist
halt so weit voneinander entfernt da
muss man auf solche Chancen wie so ein
Dreh hoffen dass man mal wieder ein
bisschen quality time zusammen hat
lässt grüßen ey
ey Leute jetzt schon wieder nichts
gedreht die alte von nix aber wir haben
ja einen Cocktails die ballern gedreht
da kannst du ja jetzt nicht auch noch
machen das stimmt das war halt echt
anstrengend ich und ich habe es aber so
angeteasert so ich bin in Köln ja wir
sind jetzt wieder auf dem Weg nach Hause
wir droppen nur noch kurz viel Food
essen ja das war aussieht ne ja das war
das war auch sehr wichtig ja jetzt
droppen wir die Kelly nur noch nach
Hause und dann ähm weil die da gar nicht
drinnen im Video jetzt kannst du
vielleicht ein Bild von ihm ein bitte
habe ich nicht kurz gesagt dass er rein
gekommen ist naja egal also wir können
ja mal kurz darüber sprechen wie war
denn der dreh dich toll ja ich fand es
geil ich finde es schön dass wir alle
mal wieder zusammen waren und ich fand
es einfach wundervoll ja was für Dark
Huma wir immer wieder haben den wir
natürlich nicht reinschneiden
gucken Leute ich habe jetzt auch ein
Block channel
nun heißt der Film sogar nur mit dem
Phone
hallo von Tag nächster Tag
ja heute ist schon wieder der nächste
Tag Leute letzte gestern saßen wir noch
im Auto auf dem Weg nach Hause sind
relativ gut durchgekommen und ja haben
dann noch seven and white geguckt also
ich und mein Freund doppelbogen optisch
ist das Tribute auf pandem die letzten
Adventskalender werden heute verpackt
und verlost ja wenn ihr das Video jetzt
um 12 Uhr pünktlich schaut könnt ihr
noch bis 18 Uhr rüber auf mein Instagram
Account gehen und bei dem Gewinnspiel
mitmachen das ist wahrscheinlich einfach
der letzte Post und das ist wirklich
eine XXL Verlosung also Monte und sowas
kann einpacken das ist der
premium-schritt ich habe noch gar keine
Ahnung irgendwas hier überhaupt werden
soll weil ja jetzt ähm haben wir den
Kalender gepackt es ist nur ein Kalender
geworden denn
das war jetzt nicht mehr so viel Zeug
dass man wirklich coole verschiedene
Kalender daraus machen konnte und jetzt
haben wir uns einfach dazu entschieden
dass wir einen richtig krassen Kalender
befüllen und zwar den von Sally weil da
richtig viel reingepasst hat und ja
jetzt ist das hier ein absoluter
Hauptgewinn da sind ich glaube der hat
Wert von über 500 €, also da haben wir
wirklich alles reingeknallt was hier
noch so unterwegs war und jetzt gehe ich
ein Outfit suchen bzw brauche ich
eigentlich auch nur ein Oberteil aber
Naomi feiert heute den ähm den den
reveal von etwas ja und da haben habe
ich mir was schönes zu überlegt und wer
sagt muss auch sagen und deswegen muss
ich jetzt einkaufen gehen und mir etwas
Schönes in der Farbe rot besorgen so
Einkauf erfolgreich
ich habe ein Outfit ich bin gespannt was
ihr dazu sagt
excuse me so das ist es jetzt das ist
mein großes backen
aber manchmal muss man das machen ne um
seine innere Französin zu Channel ich
muss mich jetzt schminken denn ich habe
wirklich nicht mehr so viel Zeit ich
weiß aber auch noch nicht was für ein
Look ich machen möchte meine Haare föhn
ich auf jeden Fall in so einer Welle da
mehr kann ich damit einfach nicht machen
ich habe gerade noch in letzter Sekunde
mein Video für heute hochgeladen das
allerletzte Adventskalender Video es ist
oben ja und jetzt müssen wir
ganz schnell schminken das kriegen wir
hinfahren ja es ist ein Adventskalender
nehmen wir das ist gut
für 100 Stunden wenn ich mir das mal
doppelt draufklatsche zwei Armen
hintereinander dann hört mein Gesicht
nie auf befeuchtet zu sein also
eigentlich braucht man nur etwas was 24
Stunden feucht hält wenn man es doch
jeden Abend quasi dann aufträgt
er hat voll gestunken
es kommen aber glaube ich noch ganz
schön von der Autofahrt ich habe mich
gestern Abend nicht mehr geduscht es war
ein großer Fehler weil wenn man so lange
im Auto sitzt 7 Stunden sind mehr
gefahren hat dann fühlt man sich einfach
nicht fühlt sich nicht wie man selbst an
ich bin irgendwie aber auch super
unsicher was dieses Jahr blocken ist
angeht ich habe mich eigentlich so
gefreut dass es halt immer nur einmal
die Woche quasi geplant kommt und dann
was dazu kommt kommt dazu na ja jetzt
machen wir uns mal ein bisschen hier
wach ne boah das ist Concealer macht
schon so einen Unterschied ich benutze
gar nicht mehr so viel Make-up sondern
einfach nur noch Concealer als ich das
interessiert naja ich bin ein bisschen
unsicher was angeht was ich
reinschneiden soll was nicht was was ich
aufnehmen soll wie viel ob das überhaupt
jemanden interessiert obwohl viele schon
geschrieben haben dass sie sich darauf
freuen aber irgendwie dadurch dass es
nicht täglich kommt es ist so anders ich
ach ich brauche echt noch meine Zeit um
da reinzukommen
so einmal das Outfit ich bin super spät
dran Naomi hat nämlich zwei eigene
Parfüm rausgebracht und da muss ich an
dieser Stelle sagen dieses Video ist
nicht gesponsert denn dieses Videos
nicht gesponsert wir haben es einfach
gefeiert und wir dachten es wäre eine
coole Idee dass wir in rot und rosa
kommen
[Musik]
und diese Bahn die wir gegangen sind war
die verrückteste Bar in der ich jemals
war die Cocktails waren ein absolutes
Highlight also jeder Cocktail war so
besonders da hatten wir eine grüne
halkan
[Musik]
es gab ein Cocktail in einer Muschel
es gab ein Cocktail in einem Korsett wir
hatten einen rauchendes Horn
[Musik]
thinking oh
und es kam was Gutes okay
lecker und sogar ein Cocktail in einer
Badewanne ich habe einen Drink bestellt
und er ist eine Badewanne und sie hat
gesagt ich schmeiße die Ente da rein
aber da muss ich ganz schnell trinken
damit die nicht im Wodka er sollt genau
damit sie nicht
Spongebob
oh
Fantasie
schmeckt irgendwie toll aus der Abend
mit Naomi war mega schön wir hatten eine
richtig coole Zeit und auch wenn wir so
viele Cocktails getrunken haben war ich
am Ende nicht wirklich betrunken aber
unser Portemonnaie war ganz schön leer
denn die Cocktails sind wirklich nicht
günstig
Freitag ging eigentlich ziemlich boring
an ich habe meine Steuern gemacht musste
ein paar organisatorische Sachen
erledigen aber dann sind wir einen
Tannenbaum kaufen gegangen wir sind zum
Baumarkt und wir wussten nicht was uns
da wartet wir hatten ziemlich Glück denn
die Tannenbäume kamen ersten Tag vorher
an also konnten wir einen kaufen aber in
unserer hochmütigen freudigen Tannenbaum
Kauf Stimmung haben wir uns für einen
Tannenbaum entschieden wisst ihr manche
Sachen passen zueinander wie Topf und
Deckel den Tannenbaum den wir uns
ausgesucht haben
ich sag mal so der ist nicht der
richtige Deckel zu unserem wohnungs-topf
[Musik]
mir Alter
Stopp okay jetzt müssen die machen der
wird doch aber alles von allen Seiten
creation
glaubst du jetzt ziehen wir ein bisschen
mehr zum zum Couch
[Musik]
oder ja scheiße und der hängt sich noch
aus und der hängt sich ja noch aus
wenn wir
uns hier reingeholt
nicht super
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
was ist denn das jetzt
zu groß
also irgendwann verkaufen
er war viel zu groß und nachdem uns das
klar war hatten wir erstmal eine kleine
sinneskrise weil darüber nachzudenken
ihn zurecht zu schneiden kam uns
irgendwie sehr brutal vor was wir dann
aber am Ende doch gemacht haben und die
Zuschnitte oder die Abschnitte die wir
von dem Baum haben haben wir eine Kiste
gepackt und werden sie an unsere
Nachbarn verteilen denn daraus kann man
noch super Adventskränze und Deko für
die Weihnachtszeit machen also es ist
nicht verloren es war ein kleines
Trostpflaster trotzdem war das ein sehr
komischer Moment es ist einfach dieser
struggle finde ich wie mit einem im
Leben man weiß ja man macht viele Sachen
falsch z.B wenn man Fleisch ist weiß man
dass man negative Sachen unterstützt
wenn man sich ein Weihnachtsbaum nach
Hause holt weiß man dass es eigentlich
nicht die beste Alternative ist ich
hatte tatsächlich in der Vergangenheit
schon mal Weihnachtsbäume auch gemietet
oder Alternativen gesucht aber die haben
sich am Ende immer herausgestellt als
dann doch gar nicht so gut also
ja wir haben eine E-Mail bekommen von
unserem tollen nachhaltigen
Weihnachtsbaum der so teuer war dass es
schon echt weh getan hat und in dieser
e-Mail stand einfach ja also die Bäume
haben sich geschafft
die sind alle auch dort und wir haben
das alles verarbeitet wir konnten
unseren Frieden damit schließen und
endlich dekorieren
[Musik]
dann haben wir es noch mit der
Lichterkette verkackt und unser Karma
war an dem Tag allgemein nicht so gut da
wir unsere lange Lichterkette schon für
etwas anderes gebraucht haben haben wir
zwei Lichterketten an diesem
Weihnachtsbaum gemacht und jetzt fragt
ihr euch schon richtig ja habt ihr denn
vorher gecheckt ob diese beiden
Lichterketten die gleiche Farbe haben
also die gleiche Lichtfarbe nein es ist
nicht dann wir mussten sie wieder
komplett abmachen dann mussten wir die
lange Lichterkette die wir woanders
angebracht haben auch abmachen und dann
konnten wir die Lichterkette an unseren
Tannenbaum bringen und es sieht wirklich
so schön aus also jetzt werden ein
bisschen zugeschnitten ist und diese
Lichterkette hat mach die absolute
Krönung und der Startschuss in die
Weihnachtszeit ist für mich persönlich
aber wenn wir die Christbaumkugeln
anbringen denn die Christbaumkugeln sind
einerseits schön weil sie einfach sehr
dekorativ sind aber wir haben auch sehr
viele Christbaumkugel mit einem hohen
emotionalen Wert denn wir haben sie auf
Reisen gekauft oder in Situationen in
denen wir besonders happy waren und ja
es ist einfach so eine Ansammlung an
Erinnerungsstücken ich habe auch
Christbaumkugeln die selbst gebastelt
von meiner Nichte sind die ich schon
seit zehn Jahren an diesen
Weihnachtsbaum bringen wir emotionale
Situation für mich und jetzt wo er so
schön im Hintergrund auch
steht wenn ich jetzt komplett in
Weihnachtsstimmung und ich hoffe dass
ich euch mit diesem Vlog oder mit diesem
ersten Block mit Video jetzt auch ein
bisschen im Weihnachtsstimmung versetzen
konnte vielleicht habt ihr jetzt selber
Lust bekommen schon bei euch zu
dekorieren und ich weiß wir sind früh
dran ja man braucht jetzt noch kein
Christbaum aber das ist bei uns
irgendwie Tradition ihn so schnell wie
möglich aufzustellen ich weiß dass viele
Familien den Baum erst kurz vor
Weihnachten hinstellen aber das ist mir
ehrlich gesagt zu kurz dafür dass es ein
ganzer Baum ist und dass der ja
eigentlich so eine schöne weihnachtliche
Stimmung bringt wenn wir das viel zu
schade den erst Sau spät aufzustellen
genau und man sollte ja am Ende seine
eigenen weihnachtsrituale schaffen und
sich eine schöne Zeit machen und wir
sehen uns dann das nächste Mal wieder
und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt wann
erzählt sie das denn alles ja eine
Stunde später nachdem wir diesen Baum
fertig dekoriert haben um 1:11 Uhr
nur weil wir den Baum im Hintergrund
haben wollten für das erste Advent video
wir haben durchgezogen wir haben es
geschafft und jetzt gehe ich ins Bett
schlafen